I got a marriage proposal on a first
date that's what
is yeah this was a really interesting
cuz it's really interesting like I guess
like being well famous or I mean I
famous I don't know but like um because
it's like you'll go on a date and they
know everything about it's like not even
like it's different if I can equally
like research you do you then we're on
equal grounds like I can find out
everything about you and you can find
everything out about me but if it's just
onesided yeah so this guy asked me on a
date and I was like okay and yeah on the
first date he was like yeah I I know you
said that um like you this is what you
look for like on this podcast and you
don't need that much time to decide if
you want to marry someone so so yeah and
I was like wow I'm eating my words right
now